Grammy award-winning singer and
songwriter and superstar Taylor Swift is
promising to help victims of sexual
assault after winning her civil suit
against a former radio host who she says
groped her a jury of six women and two
men ruled in Taylor's favor after nearly
four hours of deliberation
she says former DJ David Mueller group
groped her brother as they posed for
this pre concert photo back in 2013
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network that CBS n is here with reaction
to the trials outcome lad good morning
good morning on Friday a judge dismissed
David Mueller's claim that Swift got him
fired from his job as a radio host on
Monday the jury followed suit rejecting
Mueller's claims at the stars mother and
one of Swiss managers cost him his job
[Music]
after four years trying to keep her
assault quiet Taylor Swift made herself
heard on Monday in Taylor Swift has told
everyone
this is it the lines drawn outside the
Denver courthouse attorney Douglas
Baldrige characterized his clients
victory as more than a win not just a
win but something that can make a
difference for my kids your kids all of
us
the superstar vowed to donate to
organizations that help sexual assault
victims defend themselves saying in a
statement I acknowledge my ability to
shoulder the enormous cost of defending
myself in a trial like this my hope is
to help those whose voices should also
be heard fans who were in the courtroom
described Swift's reaction to the
verdict but earlier in the day during
closing arguments the 27 year-old broke
down in tears
David Mueller's attorney Gabriel
McFarland question why Swift was smiling
in a photo that supposedly captured the
2013 groping look at MS Swift's face is
that the face of someone who's in shock
who is upset Swift was awarded a
symbolic $1 on Monday saying she wants
to serve as an example for women who
have been sexually assaulted Taylor
Swift is one of my role models and when
she stood up like by being in that
courtroom she's standing up for women
all around the world and I just think
that's amazing
following the verdict mule his attorney
said in a statement I'm disappointed for
mr. Mueller but respect the jury's
decision
according to the Associated Press
Mueller said after trying to clear his
name for the past four years going to
court was his only option Nora all right
thank you glad we don't mess it don't
mess with terror and the message that it
sends to women young women women of all
ages a message it's in incredibly
important